I've seen things you people wouldn't
believe a small child riding on a giant
cabbage touching the face of Oprah but
sauce was this that happened not even
that's not even the started now that
actually was pretty up there and then
what the fuck no that's I asked that
word started but that's probably worth
like climaxed oh I climb eric says I
climax hard and I have in this movie I
am NOT I laughed so hard I made just
myself just I couldn't like I honestly
thought I was gonna get kicked out of
the theater because I started laughing
at one point yeah and then I think it
was like three and a half minutes
straight I wasn't addressing my shit but
Oprah's ego does a very good performance
it was into a cuz I read this about
behind the scenes where they're saying
you had to play this this giant heavenly
goddess who actually looms over
everybody and she says and they're only
we got put effects a makeup and she said
no no my ego does that naturally in fact
if you notice you didn't even ask me to
audition I'm just kind of here and I
already have the part in there like
you're right I don't remember calling
you we just had this part of this
goddess just different smiles over
everybody and that wasn't making us all
know I heard in glitter at all times it
exudes from her skin they have the
makeup to cover up the glitter you know
because now that she's gonna be our next
president cuz you know we don't vote for
politicians anymore
don't we have enough egos in the White
House my god this yeah I'm I wasn't as
bad as you but that that was wrong
that was really rough I any time she
popped on screen I completely freaking
lost it I just it's like I've never and
I will say this they say laughter is the
best medicine
I'm gonna die when I'm 150 now like I
think this movie added 50 years to my
life cuz I it was it was pure laughter
like it was the sort of laughter was
uncomplaining listen stop this is that
they're flying on just thinking of this
makes of a grasshopper and
the sprite from Fantasia 2000 and their
two flying or a giant Oprah who just all
time like this
and the little boy just hold out his
hand to touch and she giant Oprah
kind of gives it look like yes you made
touches her cheek flying around her I'm
um I'm sorry it kind of not quite get it
never got quite as good as that no it's
just what's the way Oprah just smiled
like like like touched me a little boy
stroked my face I may have a little bit
of my godliness literally looking like a
tin foil dressed chicken when a woman
dressed in a tin foil chicken suit let
it lie advertising chick-fil-a I don't
know this vision puked on miyajima white
hair and then Jem and the Holograms
style glitter everywhere like she I
couldn't tell if she was doing like Tina
Turner eighties pop you know MTV star
thing or like David Bowie and labyrinth
like it was just like fucking everything
it was just Oprah it was just a friend
so she like popped up but ever since a
bingo bingo
just cuz she just shows up like in the
movies just like Oh Oprah ya know like
the minute like they're even like you
hear her voice and like who is then
they're like oh it's her oh you're gonna
be so impressed I might just leaned over
it's like Oprah got this role huh you
know everything is around Hervey Bay in
in the heavenly glow cuz she is oh god
oh so okay so yeah the movie we had to
get that out there because we that's all
we were talking about even when she was
not on cuz if I think about it for
another second I'll start laughing
now remember they give their gifts in
the middle of the movie everyone gives
them like a physical thing this will
help you see shit and this will help you
jump through time and Oprah's like I
will give you words of wisdom because
they are that powerful like can you give
us a gun this is a No just press command
now you all know this and it's stick
together like oh no shit
now you might know the scary thing that
actually was in the book we give you
gifts and I swear to God like the books
got strong Christian overtones all it's
like that Robot Chicken peanuts get over
tones and like I swear to God the three
of them give gifts it's like that scene
in Sleeping Beauty with the fairies and
it's like and I is the last fairy
goddess of light will bestow upon you
the gift of Scripture something
something something Jesus said this mark
24 $5 as Santa Claus
light swords now happened in the book
and I just laughed because I'm like hmm
looks like we took out the strong
Christian overtones and now it's just
words of wisdom but I was like I
wouldn't killed if they kept that in
because Oprah's is like I give you my
gift
y'all me Jesus all right when we should
talk about yes is it a good movie hell
that's complicated
it's very so the first half is the most
expensive Disney Channel original movie
I've seen like pretty much the acting
the atmosphere the town everything after
sitting through those Disney separate
it's like an okay Disney Channel
original movie that just somehow got
this batshit insane budge honestly I
thought it was the most ambitious Mindy
project episode I mean it nearly an hour
40 minutes long and with a budget like
them and and they saw blinder - she what
Mindy wasn't even the main character
this plays a long game with though I
don't really ride that punch line
Oh Mindy's that I honestly she I know do
we talk about the differences between
the book and well let's talk a little
bit just I never read the book I had no
idea i asked you actually straight up I
was like have you ever heard the book
and you were just like no I know nothing
about this going into and I said oh if
it's even 50% like the book you're in
versus exactly that shit and that was
exactly what it was about 50% of the
book from from what you were describing
the stuff that was like the book
actually legit enjoyed it was the better
part yes okay so pretty much just
quickly summing up thoughts in the first
half is kind of like Disney Channel
original movie Bridge to Terabithia
Terry but there's a little bit of a like
James Cameron Avatar light yeah like but
there's people that that like that I
can't say it's awful I feel like if I
was 12 years old or younger I would
probably dig this no it was a very just
light checklist II these scenes happen
in the book get through kind of quickly
and then they change some things and but
but everyone talking really whimsically
and really in kind of these riddles are
like aha we haven't figured out it's
kind of that talk which and again as a
kid I would like Morgan now it just
seems like pretentious shite the problem
is in the book like yeah they talk like
that but it's there's something charming
about it again I'd be very difficult to
do it yeah it's hard to trans in the
film but I can tell you this in the book
I think the fucking main um that I
forget who zooms what's it who's it
where's it but the the lead one the
Oprah one in the book I thought like she
didn't have like a form if I'm gonna
fucking correct me in the comments I
know y'all will but I thought she didn't
have like some sort of stuff it's like
she was almost like a light or something
it was like really calm that's no big
Oprah all the things that may have been
in the book she was
not dressed in a tinfoil chicken suit
like that wasn't that in there so I'm
just like it's like maybe this could
have worked if you didn't make them look
that ridiculous like okay in a weird way
the only one that worked was Mindy like
that was the one when I think back like
when I think of what I thought of those
three in the book what my image of them
was is closest to Mindy I'm late Chris
Tucker what she did that she quoted
Chris Ducker don't remember
Oprah shut up and she's like you catchy
I'm talking about the look and I know
they changed it a diet let's just make
this clear got a movie it is yeah she's
nothing but quotes and them reference
who says it because it's that kind of
movie and at some point oh it whatever
one of them changes their to foreign she
just goes yeah like Tucker American and
it's like yeah we're doing this in the
book by the way she spoke like 12
languages that has now been dumbed down
to your fortune cookie sayings and Chris
Tucker and then when she was talking
normal like youth there's not much time
you have to hurry it's like wait what's
a mayor did she actually use regular
words like talk normal like speak to us
and it's like her powers are getting
weaker and it's like wouldn't it be like
she be getting weaker she just quoted
wiki quotes I mean like like anyone can
we start Infowars literally a computer
can do this I mean why why is she
getting wiig-y about it okay so then
then the second half I think it's a
second half time kind of standstill in
this movie
okay as you will when they get to this
hold stuff yes full when they get to the
suburban neighborhood that you see in
the trailer all the kids are bound it
bouncing the balls and stuff like that
then on it's kind of interesting it's
hard to say whether or not it's like
good but it's like I'm into it I want to
see where it's going and and it's weird
and it's out but I'm enjoying the weird
and oddness it doesn't feel pretentious
it feels like it's getting somewhere and
there's a legit really good emotional
moment between the main character and
her father where I was just like is that
was a real movie right yeah like that
was yes so good and her love interest is
so bad
but we'll get to that we'll get to that
see that seemed they shared that like
that was the first time the suburban
scene was close to the book but there is
still from what I remember there it
couple did but that scene I'm just like
there it is there's the book for some
reason somehow you got the book right
there where they're reunited I'm like
that is the book you freakin nailed it
like now if you could have just done
that for the rest of the movie like yes
sort of yes sir that last third I kind
of thought that's them especially with
this director I kind of thought that's
the movie I was gonna get like surreal
imagery with abstract ideas but some
real legit emotion like in the middle
yeah and like what feels like real
acting and throughout the majority of it
that's not the acting really ranges in
terms of like strangeness and
awkwardness and we'll get to that but
you're right the main kid is very is
very good like even when she has to say
katha sorry if she if she survives this
movie if this movie doesn't tank
everybody involved except for Chris Pine
and you know well that's because she's
got a billion that the only thing that
matches Oprah's ego is her bank account
so she'll be fine but besides those who
she survives this movie then she's gonna
be one to look out for cuz I feel like
if she stays in acting I'm like that
kids really nailed it yeah but and then
like in others though it's a mixed bag
yeah and we'll get to that but and then
like it kind of gets to the end and it's
it's council on down getting a little
dollars doll areas in this movie and
then like those three come back Oprah
ever ease Witherspoon and Mindy and a
bad movies return yeah that's why I said
I feel like the bad movie just returned
like it's like we're actually almost
kind of getting somewhere interesting I
wanted I want to just look straight at
me like if you all look under your seats
you'll see something special a refund
refund for you refund for you refund for
you and and then it just kind of ants
has the happy ending you think it's
gonna get and you know even visually
like the first half of this movie like
it is gorgeous don't get me wrong but we
live in interest
time where I feel like gorgeous is
weirdly easy now because of Technology
not difficult and there's a sense where
it but the second half it's like it's
visually interesting and it's intriguing
I feel like visually interesting now has
to be tied in with you know is something
you hate or emotionally drift I feel
like the movie picked up there's
problems with this scene but I felt like
something was starting to click on when
they go to the the seer the happy more
and whatever yeah in the orange where
I'm just like this looks interesting
this is an interesting metaphor they're
all teeter-tottering and and she's the
girl as always as like selling it with
her performance I may have in there for
a while though yeah it's the scenes got
problems but I felt like you know what
it's starting to take itself maybe a
little more seriously now like I don't
know I felt like it was starting to but
you're right it's not there's a lot of
problems but I'm starting to turn on
there where I'm like I'm recognizing
this feeling like the book and then they
end up going to I remember the planets
name but where they fight it and there's
I see your ID what is it it it's IT have
you tried tennis have you tried turning
the evening off again I was this close
to wearing my Tim Curry it shirt today
it's like dammit I didn't know the man
with the red eyes and central central
central intelligence or whatever so I
love I mean so okay art I mean just we
can't say it's really good I think
there's an audience for it I don't think
it's big I can see this kind of catching
I can't like how Dark Crystal caught on
years later and stuff like it'll get
this very distinct oh it's a very campy
look if you want to see something that
you will probably unintentionally laugh
at and unintentionally laugh hard just
gonna be us maybe I don't know there is
nothing funnier to me than Oprah dressed
as an aluminum chicken but I think
that's that's like a very disease no
come on what she's
really like oh no no I find it hilarious
she's 60 feet tall like literally
there's a seed wish landing no no no no
shut up I'm gonna finish this there's
literally a scene where she's standing
in the backyard and the girls backyard
and she is 60 feet tall and literally
like the height of the roof of the house
just staring down like this yes my child
and it's how can you not laugh okay
there's about what does he wear I swear
she's dressed as a fish it's like
freaking Little Mermaid gonna it's
bizarre okay this this screaming first
of all it did not have many what 20
people something like that did not that
many people know which like I'm telling
I'm assuming it's not like opening now
well that 20 but even then we were kind
of the only ones laughing at that so I'm
just going by the percentage this is
what that sure other people laugh at but
I'm sure the other people want to kick
us out but yeah I couldn't help it I do
but legit enjoy this film I can see
people like oh like an ironically yeah
no I didn't see people like grow up for
that
ya know I was saying if I was 12 or
below I feel like I would like this
movie on ironically I would like it you
know because it does talk about sort of
these interesting ideas you know that
like I think sort of tap into going into
TEENhood like you know you can't well I
think more abstract but also emotionally
too but feeling with these scientific
ideas and like I would dig that um it's
a weird combo because it doesn't really
talk down to children but in my opinion
is not taking them as seriously as the
book didn't know everyone talks in this
sense of wonder particularly the three
yeah this is or whatever it's like in
the book but I just there's a distance
I'm out of the book I was like I don't
remember being this annoying to I guess
maybe your mind fills it in how they
talk and speak but I was like I don't
remember yeah this annoying no no I'm
sure those words are from the book but
not all know by me I'm sure this is why
it's very difficult to adapt you need
actors that can make this sound quirky
and real and even Wilder like if you had
a Willie man going on like that you need
and yeah Willy Wonka that character in
in Willy Wonka you know obviously can be
screwed up very easily but you get a mad
genius like Gene Wilder in there and
it's just incredible and I feel like
yeah you needed like three Gene Wilder's
for these roles and I don't know it's
hard because I'm like trying to Gene
Wilder's when I get I'm trying to think
if there's a female equivalent like who
I could see in these roles I honestly
thought Mindy was close enough I think
the problem there's writing I thought
she was pretty
no I compared compared to Reese
Witherspoon oh that one was killer and
then the thing is Oprah though I was
just laughing at so yeah I imagine they
would be like like a cosmic Miss Frizzle
or whatever from the Magic School when I
read the book know if they were saying
these lines kind of like how the gems
from Steven universe saved their lives
there's a good comparison okay
yeah the gems yeah if they have like
those personalities and those kind of
deliveries and still sing the same lines
like I feel like it could work you know
you could connect with them and yeah
we're still kind of all-knowing to know
more than you but they're also kind of
quirky there's something you can relate
to women they're trying to be that it
yeah they did not come off like I at
least from what I can remember yeah but
okay and let's start with the other
performances in this cuz you know like I
said the first half a little kid is okay
so there's a lot of good or bad but he
fun okay I'll say he's good okay here's
my I'm on the fence but he was
interesting to watch no I am that okay
here's the thing I think this kid was
given the direction you are actually a
kid genius you're lightyears ahead of
your time you know and I want you to act
like it and when that's exactly week
it's in and it's yeah ugly over the top
and you go easy he goes dark in the
second half and it's a blast it's so cuz
and that's exactly I think what the
director was because you very much it's
like hello father
Oh should I call you father yes this is
like a South Park here coupon is so much
fun he's obviously he is what Anakin
Skywalker could have been if you started
walking like this is what the
five-year-old evil and again could have
been there's never a moment where you
feel like that kid is phoning it no he's
trying like I don't know if it's a great
performance of just campy but if it's
you don't it's like garlic stored
securely and
bam in a Robin I I love it I don't care
if it's good or bad I just love it it's
yeah amazing I mean and I think for that
age like he becomes like because again I
can totally see what they're telling him
to do and he did it and he did it to the
best of his ability and it's like for
this already weird world you know I felt
like you had a lot of passion he was fun
to watch and I was I was with him in the
boat he's supposed to be kind of lay
like I really I remember he had like
this vocabulary and it was like from the
beginning like he could just kind of you
like read minds or shit like yeah it's
not real it is in no way a real
performance but it's something where it
is just so over the top it's like I'm
always with it even when he's evil when
he's evil he's legit intimidating mmm
and I was really impressed by him
actually I was just like okay I'm
totally buying this you as a bad guy I
got the better part of the movies oh
yeah closer parts of the book and then
there's a love interest yeah okay so
this this poor kid Calvin and he looks
like he just dropped out of a Calvin
Klein commercial if you saw the greatest
showman with Hugh Jackman like that's
kind with this performance just
everything's just oh they're like you
really just shows up out of nowhere just
hi my like hi Calvin
I only know they know who he is he's
like what are you doing it's a I don't
know I just felt like I should be he's
got this weird Sam you better hold this
compartment like he's like when Jim
Carrey tries to act dramatic I just
don't know who I am don't you have a
memory play
he keeps saying like like there's a
scene at the end where it's like he
keeps staring at her as he's walking out
the kitchen door and I'm just like is he
gonna come back with a butcher knife
yeah he keeps doing that and then like
he looks through the window and then the
brother like waves cabeza yeah I'm just
like I just expect him just to come back
in the wind again like what yeah I mean
I'm election you like it was it's weird
there's even a scene where like he's
supposed to be eat like he's super
hungry he's supposed to be eating this
food the characters oh really
dumbass yeah by the way he's must be
whimsical and like in trance and
everything and he is so friggin stupid
you could literally cut him from this
movie and not miss a thing
Thank You romantic interests was it was
way worse here but I do feel like in the
book is he a jock I know I I feel like
he was a little more on the the girl and
the little brother and there were
characters I think they cut too they
were like she had more something's in
the site they were the smart ones
I don't think Calvin was ever if I
remember it right but I just couldn't
get what he was what he was doing
I took a read um in this movie I always
kind of say like I don't know it with
one takes like Sam divorces yeah he just
didn't see Dan he just looks at my
friend is like it turns to say this and
he just sits there and looks at like and
I'm like I would be going like spinning
boom everything he's just wow you know
he's like uh Mark Wahlberg from The
Happening you think it and it's a shame
cuz she's so good and she gets paired
with this schmuck I mean with with kid
actors yeah I don't know I feel like you
can't blame the kid really why blame I
blame casting I'll tell you what I'll
tell you the other problem is just
unfortunate yeah I'll tell you what the
other problem here yeah no I you can
never blame a trial at after you're 18
then I can start say maybe you're not
turning in your best performance hanging
under 18 I'm like okay you know what
this example you're it's casting or the
director like somebody signed off on you
and they should have seen that there was
a problem yeah the best example the kid
from Smurfs 2 you remember I mean one of
the worth kid actors you've ever seen
same kid from room he was nominated for
an Oscar I think yeah like so who knows
just depends I will say this my wife
called it
she totally called it cuz of the moon
she's like why does he keep sounding
British all of a sudden it was yes she
looked it up on the phone if it's always
Australia and I'm like okay so he
couldn't hide his accent as why he's
like Hugh Jackman for great
show me I didn't notice it just because
I was so entranced by over I didn't know
it either actually caught it yes going
into this like British he kind of
sounding accent and it was Australian it
turns out and and there's boys in the
movie to there just say it's the ones
where it's like they stand behind the
main bully who just goes up her and her
father disappears is just like you know
oh you should disappeared with him it's
like it's one of those gin there and
then they tried to give her like a bit
of an artist and she's thrilled
cuz like she'll just open the window
just stare at them like oh yeah with the
guy out there and then he waves or the
way she turns around it's like do you
have no idea like this is person that
directed goddamn Selma you know help all
these work and it's like they don't just
take a huh huh huh huh and even when
they come back from their adventure she
still there huh huh like no they're
gonna shout shit at you hey loser
anybody doing Maura laughter so it's
like well the way she she works around
from the window when she sees that the
guy is like interested and in Meg or
whatever and like I swear she does this
twirl and I could just hear just like oh
god it's just so I don't know I mean
they tried to give her a backstory for a
split second and the same thing with the
boyfriend or if it even is a play for
someone thing is funny because the guy
who played Martin Luther King of mad
voices the it and he's amazed mmm that
was another good casting choice his
voice has not long no he's not in it
long which it was but he's got a very uh
Keith David quality - yeah we thought
was yeah I thought it was for a second
it was like well there's a British he
kind of sound against maybe I don't know
okay yes you read the book I know it's
been a while but okay the main kid in
this uh it sounded like they were really
building up like if the brother at one
point says you know so-and-so wasn't
pretty when she was younger and look at
her now she's and she's like oh I just
always looked so awkward I wish I made
this girl we'll look how you niggas want
to look no no that's yeah there's a
fucking Hollywood yeah
is a beautiful kid I know this could be
a mom but Doug she has glasses I mean no
honestly when they're showing the other
girl like this I was tempted to be you
know this other girl and I'm like I
think the way she looks is prettier I
mean really this is a Hollywood problem
I'm sick of this thing and ready player
ones gonna have the same promise and
look at the cast at that I'm is like oh
yeah like he looks like a gamer sure it
but they didn't like in the book they've
definitely made it it's like she thinks
she's hideous she thinks she's really
ugly
she's got braces her hair is always
messy or something even a little brother
it's reference he's dreaming I got this
like from the book from what I remember
like very geeky like I get that in the
in the movie like the actress is great
but they did not like they needed to
from / up more something if that's the
idea like oh she's an outcast cuz she's
so ugly or weird or geeky together and
it just she just looks like any issue
she's not like throwing on the Lumis
hooker makeup collection like maybe some
of the other girls are but she looks
like any average kid there I could 100%
shear in a picture frame yeah like you
know that you sell to sell a frame I
mean it just yeah all they did to
basically separate them was they put the
other the mean girls in shorter skirts
and more makeup and I think they were
all a little taller than her - other
than that oh and I don't think they wore
glasses like that that's the big days so
ya know you you freakin nailed that I
wasn't thinking about that till after
the fact well I was just watching cuz
when the brother said I'm just like is
that what we're supposed to get out of
this no she's good there there's lots of
stuff in this movie where I suddenly go
is that what I was supposed oh my god so
Oh Malcolm saw this with us and that was
the best moment when the little kids is
there the brothers just like sick kids
it Charles Wallace sounds like uh yeah
newscaster
minutes it was kind of Charles wallet
answers well even like waves in problem
in because because when you have a kid
who can read mine sing Charles Wallace
makes him sound creepier but yeah so
Charles Wallace is like saying it's like
oh that's just like you Kevin
Yahweh's coming in to save the day I
always want to be the hero always
wanting to save everybody and the
Malcolm just is like does like everybody
could hear him say that like we were
just laughing it was that like the
climax of this movie yeah yeah think is
giving anything away head ties in to
giving in to your fears and insecurities
and like confronting them and
challenging them and I'm just thinking
to myself no she didn't she said them
she didn't do anything I felt like there
were scenes missing yeah like that like
Charles was referencing things that will
be in the director's cut I don't know
what and even the father he's like you
know I spent you know my life trying to
hold hands with the stars
I should have been holding hands with my
daughter and again I'm just like is that
what this was he was a bad away you
neglecting father was that I I'm gonna
sound heartless but it was now I'm not
gonna sound heartless because see when
they reunited is amazing and that got me
all like nearly misty-eyed
but that opening like all you need is
love love is everything I was just like
oh my god we're in trouble already and
it's settled down for a little bit but I
there was something about that opening
that rubbed me the wrong way just to
have that Disney fake equality about it
love love love love love and I'm like
really reminds I forget it and the book
did that dudes like yes
drat defeated by the power of love I get
it but it's just like is something about
the way that it's so advertising that
first like minute of the film and I'm
like mmm
I'm like already this is having a
brother on it's just it feels
inauthentic yeah movie that gets
strangely authentic in other moments
like there are moments with the
performances I'm like okay there it is
there's the book but there are moments
where it just it feels like a Disney
Channel movie of the week where it's
just like statement of main theme and
late particularly with the kid not being
you
really ugly or even that awkward or
anything like that I mean it just it
totally made me think of the kid in the
Bridge to Terabithia movie where it's
like she's supposed to be a tomboy she's
supposed to be weird she's supposed to
be off and it's like no she is like a
Barbie doll of whimsical enchantment do
you know I mean it's just one of those
things where I think the only scene that
felt real when it came to the bullies
was when they left the post-it note I
hope you disappear I'm a locker Mike
yeah that's some pretty petty shit I can
see that happening and it's like it of
course it's like anonymous except eveng
got the girl then shows up with her
entourage is like I just wasn't getting
why they were against this kid I mean
like I said to it if she was weird
that's it I feel like we didn't even see
her enough with other kids to understand
that I she was picked up and it was
trying that's the weird thing it was
trying so hard it was like looking like
freaking hoop dreams there's I'm like
this documentary style filmmaking with
with like the shaky cam and like now
we're gonna try to milk some drama out
of this but it I don't know it's just
like something didn't click it's like I
could see them trying so hard to be like
realistic school setting it but never
felt real despite all the tricks they
were trying to do this director did you
know Selma yes like whoa I mean like you
know just the height of you know realism
it just ugliness and fighting back and
strength and weakness I mean all these
things coming together I mean just so
much of a you spirit and this just feels
very this might be a lot it is mean oh
well okay I think we're answering our
own question yeah how could she do
something so base like calculated Disney
that's why I'm saying like sir the what
what's seem to be what seemed to be her
strength as a director it felt like is
not represented here for whatever reason
I'm guessing yes kind of it is
part of the problem is the book - I
don't think this is a book that is easy
to adapt and I don't think the the book
was so if you've never had the book it's
and it feels weird and it I'm not sure
that trying to make it hyper-realistic
like they're trying to do is the right
way to go um I mean you could do a
particularly what you have Oprah dressed
in the aluminum chicken suit well yeah
you just have to do involved well you to
do the realistic well you had to do the
abstract well and I mean the abstract
they touch on a little bit more book
later on the book okay so full
disclosure I have not read the book
since the fourth grade and that was 1988
like I read in early fourth grade cuz I
went to a Catholic school and they make
you read The Hobbit in kindergarten
because they're crazy like that but yeah
we went to a private school for three or
four years and they were way ahead and I
remember reading the book and I had come
out of school in South Carolina so I was
like two years behind all these other
kids in school and it was a rut it was a
rough read that it was a good read but I
read it back then and I don't remember
the nitty-gritty of it what I do
remember it's like almost like Star Wars
or something it's it runs on feeling
like I remember the feelings of the book
evoke and I remember certain key scenes
I remember I think in the book the early
scene with the storm which I thought was
handled pretty well was also in the
movie that was there that just set the
tone for being weird cuz I remember like
it's like the little brother could kind
of like read her mind I remember reading
it as a kid like well because that was
like my worst thought that you have like
that was fucking terror right there so
and I tried a lot of things - disturbing
the thing about the book that I think
the book nailed is that feeling of
alienation and that feeling of you know
being the the weird kid or the ugly kid
or the geeky kid and trying to find your
place it like nailed those feelings even
if I do
remember everything clearly and the
thing I remember most about the book is
that scene in suburbia like when they
first go into that town I remember
reading the book and just being somehow
terrified these three lone kids or
whatever just being stared at by
everybody else who's all doing the same
thing and then the in the book it's even
weirder because everything's gray they
like these sunshiny colors but
everything's gray at the book and I
remember thinking like because we were
still at the height of the Cold War II
was like is this a communist Russia
weird gray and said and everybody does
the same thing conform conform so it
there was something about that whole
sequence and that whole sequence on that
planet the last third of that book that
really resonated and then I still
remember and that's the part of the
movie I think it nails the most and
that's the part that I think kids a lot
of times yeah ba ba ba mystical wonder
yay kids connect with fear more than
anything I think that's why 80s films
are so great I think that might be where
the problem is here if there is going to
be a time where this sort of weird-ass
movie could have worked we missed it it
would have been the 80s like I think
I've returned Ozzy's okay no you know
what I'm saying though that this 1975
through 1990 hmm you know I don't and
like maybe that style of filmmaking will
come back again it's not here now though
like everything in this I feel like
trying to jab I know it's important but
yeah it's really glossy okay really
there but then there's weird decisions
like I swear to god I'm not making this
up that book has centaurs and this movie
does not and I'm like that doesn't
surprise me
yeah but what's weird is like uh he was
just like I just think we remember their
fucking sometimes it is the three of
them are centaurs it was a planet of
centaurs
there were centaurs everywhere and what
does this one give us it's like well we
can't do the centaurs nobody will take
that seriously therefore we will have a
giant flying head of cabbage with the
voice of Reese Witherspoon and I'm like
right this looks like a giant Jolly
Green Giant ad that goes on for 20
minutes I probably was so hoping that
you were wrong about the Centaurs so
just everyone can be like why do rob
jump to that I swear I'm not crazy
please tell me I'm not crazy I haven't
read the book since 1988 but the one
thing I took out of it is communism on
alien planets is bad and such harm that
is the lesson of a wrinkle in time and
something-something believe in yourself
so but but yeah the things I took out of
the book was that sense of like fear of
being scared as a child and being lost
like that kinds of being lost in that
town and like everybody's staring at you
you're already in school every way
anyway and schools just fucking
government babysitting and it's weird
and there's kids everywhere and they
like you always feel like you're somehow
being watched either by you are your
teachers your principal you know all the
other kids and then you have to conform
with them and it's just like so I felt
that really nailed it and that's why I
think the last third part of the film
feels the most like the book to me I'm
like the stuff that's where is getting
interesting at most stuff on the planet
is I just remember it somehow being in
as weird as it sounds like I you would
think that tinfoil chicken Oprah and
flying cabbage Reese Witherspoon and and
we're talking flowers would be weird
enough but I somehow remember the book
being even weirder I remember weird sent
our things on urea or Yuri through our
whatever the planet was called and like
I just remember my mind it just came out
weirder but then again I remember I'm
also a child of the 80s mmm that was
growing up and shit like Return to Oz
and the hold over suppose maybe my mind
was just more psychic time the plus I
have books too is that you know you can
introduce ideas you know and your brain
fills in but yeah you know I'm sure when
they said the flowers are speaking in
colors like you could interpret that
like their language is colors and it's
like you could turn interpret that in a
ton of ways you know in this film
they picked away as you have to you know
but in a book
there's so many ways you could interpret
how the flowers that are talking through
colors and I feel like that's how the
book proudly work that there was a lot
more like you know insert your
visualization of how this is working or
happening I feel like the the movie
works best when it so Madeleine L'Engle
and whatever her name is she's got a
great quote and I wish I had remembered
when we were talking about Sharkboy
versus Lavagirl because we're talking
with how like yeah it's for kids with
like how much of a pass do you give for
kids and she had this great quote I
think it was her and she said the secret
to children's storytelling and
literature and the same applies to films
is to be child like without being
childish and when the movie worked it
was being childlike when it didn't work
it was being childless or child
[Laughter]
childish like those scenes near the end
it was childlike and there's some scenes
with wonder where it's darling but like
the scene where the little boy's
touching Oprah's face and he's like oh
asking my glory that's childish yeah and
there's other scenes like that so I I
feel like there's a good movie trying to
get out of this but it definitely yeah
it sounds like it's a difficult film to
sort of make I'm surprised I know she's
got a great there was a my other
favorite quote of hers was I think they
did a TV version at one point maybe on
the sci-fi channel or something cuz I
know I did but she had a quadric book
did you did you see the the live-action
adaptation and she's like oh yes it met
my expectations I expected to hate it
and that's what I did I felt like she'd
probably say the same thing about this
one there's a there's a really there's
one great line in this movie where I'm
just like that's a solid line and I
think it's the wife talking to the
husband and she says being great doesn't
just mean being right and there's a
parmi that feels even if you sort of
even if you did like a word-for-word
whatever of the book
that wouldn't make it great that make it
right that may everything else but you'd
have to sort of take it like you said
establish this atmosphere in this
connection with your audience which is
supposed to be kids you know some adults
as well and you're right there has to be
some sort of legit realism and some sort
of legit concern and fear and it's just
not established because never quite
feels genuine it always feels like well
we're trying to give you this type of
character give you this type of
experience and sometimes in the last
third it works you know which is why I
can't say this is whatever cuz there are
times where it really works but it does
not right through the whole thing and
when it doesn't it's pretty awkward
pretty silly and even kind of funny
somehow much more funny than others oh
god I know and somebody a friend of ours
rating Oprah out of context looks like
something out of kung fury where there's
a Giants in the scam yeah I'm like
that's what it looks like you don't bro
yeah it's riding giant Oprah that's
really bad quality like it's not really
there like it's almost a bad effect like
this was a joke a friend of mine saw it
early and said it's actually kind of
nostalgia critic material and for like
the first half though and at least the
first two thirds I was kind of like good
and then the last third kind of said and
I'm like III kind of like this now I'm
kind of really enjoying it so I'll be I
don't know I'll see what kind of
reception is I'll be very curious to see
how people like the book I got people
like the book won't like I don't know
what it I don't know what the average
age is for because I know people who's
like that book changed my life that book
like it taught me things about myself
and like I didn't have quite the same
experience but I've read it in what I
would think is kind of young in there
like the beginning of the fourth grade
like I feel like this is a book more for
like 12 year old yeah
is so it I will say this though the book
stuck with me I had to read that EM
Bridge to Terabithia back into the bag
think about that one then yeah our
fourth-grade teachers I think wanted us
to kill ourselves um I was Catholic no
they want us to feel guilty and then not
killers it yes to confess it later yes
but um so I didn't have the same
experience but it did stick with me
because it was so weird and even as a
kid I knew it was weird and it was like
heady concepts for a fourth grader cuz
there's like kind of quantum mechanics
and quantum physics in it and you're
being forced to accept a lot of these
things and then of course strong
Christian overtones that's what I wanted
to like it cuz I like kids stories that
do then do challenge them with kind of
abstract ideas and cuz their minds
especially can kind of be open to that
kind of stuff even more just be like oh
yeah they can kind of keep those avenues
open Barry yeah it blew my mind and
those those scenes in suburbia and the
last part of the book like resonate with
me still is one of the earliest things I
read that just legit creeped me out so
I'm really not much for conforming or
respecting Authority anyway but so I
don't know like what people who would
have read this like in their teenage
years preachy like you know kind of
twelve-year-old kind of like if you have
maybe six or seven you know I feel like
a lot of times I hear people's like that
book changed my life they were closer to
that age so I'd be very curious what
they think of this movie like cuz I did
the book was it the book stuck with me
and it was my first experience to a good
mind fuck but probably Terabithia stuck
with me a little more because it was my
first introduction to death now Disney
botched both of them and yeah just me
has now botched both of them
good job guys I I think I like this more
yeah the two I read back to bag that
we're like just like messed with me its
is like Disney wrecked both em so that's
good I guess I could bury my demons um
I'll say I like this more than bridgit
Erebus yeah I think there's no I do too
a good third may close to even half of a
movie in here no Bridge to Terabithia
like maybe 10 minutes it's only ten
minutes there but there's a longer chunk
of this that's good in this there's bits
in the middle and that there's like
moments yeah like a sprinkle sprinkle in
and like it it is pretty again I wanted
something a little more psychedelic and
it's just kind of like colorful Avenue a
little bit at the end but by that point
we're already just so tired and started
looking like an 80s movie I'm like this
is the movie I wanted it here at the end
where it's like weird or like purples
and pinks and and glitter and time warps
and it really it was like dropping acid
I feel like I'm just kind of done can we
get to the credit it's like I feel bad
cuz it's like I would love that imagery
if it was like I don't know no I know
just say your earlier but you have
nothing but you had like this long
Thomas Kincade fantasy painting where
it's just like everything's too glossy
for like a half hour so at this point
now you're just like I'm just well and
it's not even that long a parallel like
an hour forty minutes we went in at 7:00
and it's when they start the trailers at
our cinema at 7:00 the movie starts at
7:00 you sit through like 20 minutes of
trailer shows but our 40 yeah felt like
at least two so yeah there it is I think
over time this probably will get an
audience like I have among younger
viewers that like looking back and maybe
will kind of open up their minds and
stuff like if I was 12 or under I
probably like it as an adult it is just
corny I'm glad I saw because it was so
so funny and it was enjoyable and how
over-the-top it was about having that
read the book there or were you just
like was that what you were expecting or
what else expects a fuck no honestly
what I've seen the trailer when I was
expecting was kind of that last third
and particularly with the director I
really thought what I was gonna get I
felt less or the avatar magical lands
like for the most diggin it's okay
everywhere now they cut down the climax
cuz I felt like
they went somewhere when he drags her
back and they patted but I get why they
cut that cuz like no we need the we got
the dramatic we need to keep it going
they want to keep the momentum going and
I'm thankful they did that but they they
cut the climax down somehow like they
took a step out of there and then I felt
like the most shit they change was on
that first planet so I felt like that
was way different in the book but I
can't remember the book that well but
I'm like something's not I didn't even
get those planets they were yeah okay
yeah what's his play as a kid it was
just like and I'm just like a conscious
warping the planet so wrinkled in time
yeah I mean like even be a door well the
third books called like a soft wait no
it's swiftly I mean I guess a spinning
tilting planet or something yes Chris
Pine was even talking about like you
know yeah we can travel light-years we
can travel but it's like I don't know I
just thought but through the mind
through the ashes so it's like I just
thought it's just kinda like a stream of
consciousness or something that somehow
me it's okay that you'll or something
like it just me or do you think they
strangely had really good chemistry I'm
like I felt like that was a real
father-daughter relationship they had
outside of that first fight like dropped
the first five minutes and do the
reunion see that everything else
reunion on yeah that first that first
scene was just garbage all around but I
felt I'm like yeah I feel like somehow
this was really earned like I I feel
like these two were actually like a
parent and a kid like no it was very it
was strangely effective yeah no that's
why I was thinking - I'm thinking like
when they reunite I'm just like well I
know I'm not gonna feel anything cuz
they didn't have much of a connection
before I know it's just like that was
really kind of a tear-jerking seemed
like it was that it was like that that
you know when the the marine or the
soldier comes home from the war and then
Caesar yeah first time I was like that
felt really good
why all of a sudden now is the movie
turning on well yeah I don't know well
maybe that's what the directors best and
maybe that's in their wheelhouse is like
Oh authenticity and then Disney's like
no Jolly Green Giant shit have them find
something fun flowers we can't know for
sure I mean there's a church or two we
don't
it's better a more kind of like
realistic like Mouse though it's fun
good feels right it feels good you know
by the way they've been that too much
role with like Marvel and stuff like
that it's like let's stick it to them a
little bit
this is this honestly this feels like a
live-action Disney remake that kind of a
little bit yeah I will say this though
what I love though is there is a
tesseract so yes it is a Disney film
that means that a wrinkle in time is now
in the Marvel Cinematic Universe okay I
want Thor to show up it's like gonna
find the tesseract so um
quite an experienced man I remember the
book being weird as shit and so is the
movie but I think one was better
yes it sounds like the book goes better
so that's about it we'll see you next
time nigga nothin yeah me too I'm just
thinking about piranhas aluminum chicken
soup how can you not
you